I want to take a quick drive
around the city of Berlin,
I wanted to do it in an authentic way,
this is Tina, you've agreed to help me
and you brought me this car.
What is it?
[Tina] That's a Trabant.
The only car that you
could have in east Germany
was a Trabant.
Yeah.
[Conan] Is it a hard car to drive?
Yeah, I will show you.
(laughter)
[Tina] See.
[Conan] What's the problem?
Maybe we could...
Look the whole car, look
at that, look at that,
it's like a toy,
Ok.
(audience laughing)
There you go, I'm a
gentleman, are you okay Tina?
[Tina] It works.
Very good.
Look at these buttons, I mean
yes, okay, windshield wiper,
oh, that's adorable,
schloopy, schleipy, schloopy, schleipy
Don't say it like that.
Why?
It's something nasty,
(speaking in German)
What did I say, be
honest, what did I say?
Vagina something...
(audience chuckling)
The second word didn't
make any sense but you said
"vagina something"
That's what I meant to say.
Okay.
(audience laughing)
You want to get it in first
gear, you have to pull it down
[Conan] Right.
[Tina] Yes.
[Conan] Then what?
Up.
Okay, then where would third be?
Go to neutral and then pull it.
So you gotta get it
back to neutral, pull,
and then press down.
Exactly, yes, exactly.
What happens when you want to do reverse?
I think I would probably
just get out of the car
(audience laughing)
and push it back this way.
(car engine starts)
(loud muffler sounds)
Woo.
Okay, what happened there?
You need to give gas.
I did give gas.
Yeah, more.
This is a performance anxiety for me.
(laughter)
Do you know what that is?
Yes.
When a man is with a
beautiful woman and he becomes
a little nervous.
Yeah, with the shift?
With the shift, yes
(laughter)
Yes, very good.
(engine starts)
Then up, I just showed you the gears,
first I'll show you the gears
(engine revs)
(music)
[Conan] So far so good.
[Tina] So far, so good but
your only drive in first gear.
[Conan] Yeah.
[Tina] Yeah, that's easy.
Oh my god, what you doing?
Drive straight.
(Conan laughing)
(Conan speaking in German)
The problem is it's not a very good car
for romance cause if I
was on a date with you,
and it was going well and I
wanted to put my arm around you
look, I can't...
That's true.
That's very hard
Yeah.
In this car
Yes.
To get my arm around you.
Yes, maybe we should
concentrate on the car again?
(audience laughing)
Just shot down in the
shittiest car I've ever been in.
(audience laughing loudly)
It's a new low.
Do you think maybe a second date?
Maybe we just leave it like that?
(audience laughs)
All right, nice to see you.
Nice to see you.
Take care.
Bye.
(German music)